[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est une liste qui s'est constitué en
septembre dernier qui est resté uni et
solide pendant tout le temps de la
campagne et du confinement une liste
plurielle
une liste qui rassemble à la fois des
anciens élus et david prowse ya engagé
dans le monde associatif ou tout
simplement engagée sur la ville dans
diverses activités qu'il y avait l'envié
de se retrouver et de partager un projet
commun pour la ville donc une liste
plurielle je le disais expérimentés et
plein de compétences et à l'image
surtout représentative de l'ensemble des
bides provient et des habitants de la
commune notre programme on l'entend
aujourd'hui en sortie de crise par l'est
de la ville de demain et des différentes
transitions qu'il faudrait engager
transition écologique et sociale
solidaire économique notamment tout ce
toutes ces transitions là nous vous
avions déjà prévu dans notre projet dans
le programme initial de premier tour
donc il est évidemment toujours
d'actualité je pense au développement
des circuits courts je pense à une
alimentation durable
je pense également au télétravail on
avait prévu dans ce projet de créer un
espace de coworking de télétravail c'est
évidemment toujours d'actualité ou aussi
une maison de service public qui servira
aussi maintenant dans l'après crise à
accompagner les demandeurs d'emploi et
aussi tous les acteurs économiques qui
ont besoin de d'accomplir des démarches
administratives pour l'horreur lancer
leur reprise d'activité alors la
première décision ce sera de faire face
à la crise et ce sera de répondre à la
fois aux préoccupations du quotidien des
meusiens mais aussi de se projeter sur
l'avenir très proche
à commencer par la rentrée scolaire de
septembre qui sera un défi et un enjeu
aussi pour nous au niveau local avec le
retard de l'école dé ou dumoulin qui va
falloir s'adapter à cette question là on
va lancer aussi une conférence locale
des solidarités pour inventer de
nouvelles solidarités pérenniser dé
solidarité qu'on a pu voir immergé
pendant le confinement et qui convient
aujourd'hui de pérenniser notamment la
destination des personnes fragiles et
isolées
et puis évidemment on apportera tout
notre soutien aux acteurs économiques et
associatifs dans leur reprise d'activité
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]